[Musique]
et c'est beaucoup pour cette
introduction bonsoir à toutes et bonsoir
à tous je suis vraiment ravi d'être ici
ce soir parmi vous je vais essayer de
rendre la conférence accessible et aussi
compréhensible avec ma prononciation et
les idées que je suis venu vous dire
moi je suis un passionné de voyage dans
le temps
je sais pas pour vous mais en tout cas
moi j'aime bien voyager dans le temps je
n'ai pas une machine qui permet de le
faire
malheureusement je n'ai pas inventé je
l'ai pas trouvé ce que venant dans mon
jardin j'aurais bien aimé la voir aussi
mais en tout cas c'est dans les musées
que j'aime bien voyager dans le temps
dans les musées on découvre les vestiges
de beaucoup de civilisations ça nous
permet de réfléchir qu'est-ce que ces
civilisations de l'ancien temps nous ont
permis d'avoir comme information qu'on
peut transposer dans les réalités
d'aujourd'hui
je vais raconter une histoire
en histoire
je passe une fois au musée du Louvre
j'ai découvert cette pièce
je me suis dit qu'est-ce que c'est ce
n'est pas une pièce de monnaie
rassurez-vous l'écran l'appareil un peu
plus grandes mais là encore plus petite
en centimètre sur 6 il y a des
précisions dans cette pièce un oeuvre
d'art que vous pouvez l'apprécier au
musée du Louvre je voulais faire des
recherches sur cette pièce pour savoir
qu'est-ce que c'est j'ai appris c'est un
contrat de vente une maison et d'un
champ furibaque qui date de 2006 ans
2600 avant Jésus-Christ c'est très
intéressant que les personnes d'avant
ont trouvé le moyen de sceller un
contrat de confiance entre eux qui
permet de dire que le client a cédé avec
une transaction actée par cette pièce
je me suis dit c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir si nous pouvons
revivre dans le passé et leur dire que
vous pouvez homologuer votre
transactions par le papier le papier
peut faire une référence toute la vie
tout entier avec une conférence c'est
pas l'objet mais on filigrane on va
détruire le papier
lorsque j'étais diplômé on informatique
j'ai cru comprendre que ça ne suffit pas
en tout cas la presse de l'époque nous
dit il faut être double compétences être
ingénieur ce n'est pas forcément un gage
que nous permet de comprendre les
métiers
je me suis dit pourquoi pas je suis
parti à la Sorbonne j'ai trouvé une
conférence très intéressante d'un grand
économiste s'appelle monsieur Jobard
je vous renvoie plusieurs décennies en
arrière on parlait de modélisation on
parlait de globalisation moi je ne
savais pas la différence des deux mais
en tout cas c'est le terme
mondialisation qui s'est imposé avec les
économistes on disait pour que vous
juger l'économie des pays il faut
absolument mesurer le PIB et parmi les
choses qui sont intéressantes dans le
PIB il faut mesurer le delta entre
l'exportation et l'importation très
intéressant comme réflexion d'autant
plus que j'avais des amis autour de moi
qui avait la chance d'être des
importateurs exportateurs ils avaient
les oses financières ils avaient un bon
business plan un bon business model mais
ça n'a pas été suffisant pour éliminer
leur frustration de développer leur
affaire je ne savais pas qu'avec une
bonne connaissance de métier avec un
départ de financement acceptable et
raisonnable on peut avoir cette
frustration j'ai compris que justement
le trade finance c'est une activité
méconnue pour ceux qui sont pas acteurs
c'est-à-dire importateur exportateur ou
tout simplement dans le milieu bancaire
si on n'est pas dans les deux catégories
on ignore qu'il y a des besoins
satisfaire il y a des services à
améliorer
le train de finance est une activité
peut-être le sujet paraîtrait technique
mais en tout cas il est vraiment crucial
dans le développement commercial de tous
les pays du monde vous voyez bien que le
travail est un peu compliqué
qui permet justement de voir qui a
l'acheteur qui est le vendeur et que
l'acheteur lorsqu'il propose une somme
d'argent à sa banque le problème n'est
pas terminé il faut absolument que la
banque vérifie plein de documents ces
documents qu'elle doit vérifier sont
vraiment berocratiquement et avec un
temps vraiment chronophage en même temps
la banque elle veut absolument vérifier
que le acheteur il est sérieux et
qu'elle peut s'engager avec lui pour
vérifier sa transaction
le vendeur quant à lui on le connaît pas
il y a plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
c'est normal qu'on a besoin aussi de son
côté de mon dater des banques de
vérifier que l'acheteur et les sérieux
donc tout ce schéma va prendre du temps
vous avez vu aujourd'hui qu'on a parlé
du rythme dans une entreprise on a
besoin de faire plusieurs actions
commerciales en minimum de temps si on
traîne on peut perdre la
concurrenceabilité de notre entreprise
on peut perdre le fil et d'ailleurs je
vais vous raconter une anecdote qui
m'est arrivé plutôt à quelqu'un que je
connais c'est une entreprise de jouer
ils ont raté leur Noël pas parce qu'ils
n'ont pas brisé mobilisé les sommes
nécessaires qu'ils ont pas mandaté leur
banque c'est tout simplement que la
banque du vendeur a reçu les fonds très
en retard et vous êtes d'accord avec moi
que lorsqu'on reçoit la marchandise ou
les jouets le 22 janvier la saison est
terminée et elle est foutue et
d'ailleurs ils ont eu des difficultés
quelques années plus tard ils ont mis le
la crise soupe paillasson c'est vraiment
dommage donc vous remarquez bien que ce
schéma qui existe
on vous dit toujours que pour améliorer
la performance d'une entreprise ce que
j'ai dit en préambule ont détruit le
papier on améliore la digitalisation
dans une entreprise
là la blockchain rentre en jeu elle
permet justement ce qui permet d'avoir
un sujet d'introduction d'améliorer
cette confiance d'améliorer la sécurité
et la scalabilité
bien entendu le commerce international
s'adapte depuis des années des siècles
et des dessinés la blockchain est
apparue en 2008 elle apparu justement
pour mettre en lumière les difficultés
des banques
je ne vais pas critiquer les banques ce
soir parce que pour moi c'est un acteur
majeur de l'économie et moi je pense
qu'il faut absolument travailler avec
eux mais dans la main pour améliorer
beaucoup de process
la blockchain avec ce trilemme que vous
regardez il est basé sur la sécurité
c'est très important aussi la
décentralisation par laquelle vous
imaginez que si chacun d'entre vous il a
un nœud il a un ordinateur qui permet
d'avoir un copie de registre c'est un
ordinateur d'entre vous tombant en panne
on a toujours la copie d'information on
a aussi la scalabilité c'est à dire
combien d'informations on pourrait plus
ou moins avoir c'est très important
d'augmenter la scalabilité le seul souci
de la blockchain ce que ce trinôme on
peut pas le changer et il faut
absolument baisser un critère pour
améliorer un autre mais on peut pas
améliorer les trois niveaux
comment fonctionner la blockchain je ne
vais pas expliquer dans le détail mais
je vais essayer de donner quelques
informations elles sont composées sur T4
piliers la formation sécurisée
chaque information est dans un bloc la
blockchain ne vérifie pas l'information
qu'elle soit juste elle dit simplement
ce que vous avez dites et inscrite et
vous ne pouvez plus changer d'avis si on
inscrit dans la blockchain 1+1=5 c'est
fini on va dire que mercredi soir on a
dit que 1 + 1 = 5 on va le mettre dans
un bloc qui va avoir la validation et
que les tous les validateurs vont
vérifier
l'information et l'exactitude de cette
information on va la crypter et à partir
de cela elle va être horodatée et elle
va être humain comme information
vous allez me dire la blockchain permet
de vérifier les données sont données on
n'a pas de blockchain on n'a pas de
transmuration d'information la
blockchain permet de améliorer le cycle
de vente et de paiement ce qui les
banques se sont intéressés aussi de les
avoir
lorsqu'on paye une banque qui s'apprend
trois semaines vous êtes d'accord avec
moi c'est un problème il y a 30 ans en
arrière il fallait trois semaines après
c'est devenu deux semaines maintenant
une semaine bien entendu on parle pas de
quelques milliers d'euros on parle de
millions de centaines de millions de
milliards c'est pas la même chose
lorsque l'on va faire un virement un
locataire auprès de son propriétaire ça
c'est des grandes sommes d'argent
la blockchain a permis de résoudre ce
problème lorsque Monsieur X avec son
entreprise souhaite faire une
transaction financière de paiement
il y a plusieurs transactions qui vont
être enregistrées dans un bloc vérifiez
et le bloc va être audité par les
validateurs ce qu'on appelle les mineurs
en fonction de Black la blockchain
utilisé on a un protocole différent mais
en tout cas les validateurs travaillent
la même façon afin de vérifier la
formation et la tamponner et l'euro
d'Athènes
une fois qu'elle est hors datée
enregistrée et inscrite le nouveau bloc
il est vraiment inclus dans la
blockchain avec tous les nœuds qui
constituent le réseau et on peut plus la
changer mais en tout cas de facto en
quelques dizaines de minutes monsieur Y
ou l'entreprise monsieur y reçoit la
transaction donc on permet justement
d'améliorer le rythme et permettre à
l'entreprise d'avoir une exploitation
beaucoup plus grande parce que si vous
faites une opération par mois
vous allez être battu par une entreprise
qui fait deux opérations par mois et
ainsi de suite ça c'est vraiment le
préambule de l'exploitation d'une
entreprise
on dit toujours que le cercle c'est
vraiment le meilleur sens de définir la
confiance et d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
choisi vous avez quand même un cercle
qui est défini par tous les nœuds qui
constitué la blockchain tout le monde a
accès un temps réel à toutes les
informations on est améliore la
productivité on améliore la confiance
une améliore la transparence des
informations donc là vous remarquez bien
que la banque du client plutôt de
l'acheteur a accès aux informations elle
va transmettre des informations plus
rapidement au vendeur que lui-même a
accès avec sa banque ou la tutelle de
son paiement d'avoir des informations
nécessaires donc vous remarquez que dans
le vendeur n'a pas reçu le paiement et
toutes les informations il ne peut pas
donner instruction avoir à mettre la
marchandise sur bateau parce que c'est
quand même le moyen le plus utilisé dans
le commerce international même si on a
aussi l'utilisation exceptionnelle de
l'avion et d'autres moyens et c'est le
transport maritime qui représente ente
la plus grande partie du commerce
international et là si c'était monsieur
qui attendait les jouets pour enfants et
l'aurait reçu rapidement sa marchandise
et que finalement les personnes et les
clients seront ravis d'avoir leur
mensualisme à temps
la blockchain non seulement elle est
active pour valider et pouvoir faciliter
le paiement on peut l'avoir sur
plusieurs choses et plusieurs briques on
peut l'avoir dans l'audit la
transparence si on va avoir une banque
l'idée de ne pas de remplacer les
banques l'idée c'est travailler avec eux
afin de pouvoir utiliser les ressources
humaines d'une banque au meilleur tâche
et les tâches redondantes les tâches
répétitives il faut absolument les
mettre des personnes moins qualifiées ou
tout simplement les automatiser on a la
collaboration on a une meilleure
efficience on a l'autonomie et on a
aussi toute une question de éviter la
fraude
aujourd'hui avant de venir à cette
conférence j'ai vu un article c'était
pas volontaire qu'une personne a loupé
32000 euros de virement envers une
banque et que la banque n'a pas reconnu
la erreur elle a dit je l'ai reçu par
papier et que finalement
jusqu'aujourd'hui vous pourriez vérifier
l'information et un conflit entre le
client et sa banque mais en général les
banques ils ont fait des efforts
extraordinaires ils ont accompagné le
commerce ils ont accompagné tous les
acteurs et moi je salue cet effort ils
étaient incriminés après la crise de
2008 mais il faut pas oublier que c'est
un acteur majeur de l'économie qu'il
faut absolument travailler avec eux
avant d'arriver à la conclusion j'ai
prêté de bonnes intentions à la
blockchain et est-ce que c'est vraiment
suffisant est-ce qu'elle est vraiment
toute seule qui pourrait imposer des
solutions innovantes la réponse est non
malheureusement si on peut pas améliorer
le cadre juridique et réglementaire si
on peut pas être d'accord sur un cadre
commun s'il n'y a pas des parties
prenantes si on ne peut pas améliorer ça
a été dit la formation la culture on
pourrait pas justement améliorer
l'adhésion il y a des entreprises qui
disent que la blockchain c'est compliqué
mais s'il suffit de rester avec quelques
jours quelques semaines et disent
finalement on est d'accord il faut
absolument résoudre le problème de ne
pas remplacer tout le système des
entreprises
si vous cherchez un autre si vous
cherchez du travail et si vous voulez
entreprendre il faut absolument
connaître le métier aujourd'hui je vous
ai fait une fenêtre de tir sur un milieu
qui méconnu de beaucoup de personnes
mais à d'autres domaines auxquels on
peut participer et on peut innover ça
peut être dans la santé il faut
connaître le métier ça peut être dans
les entreprises de digitalisation mais
il faut connaître le métier la
technologie seul ne suffit pas
d'ailleurs une anecdote comme je suis en
contact avec les entrepreneurs je vois
toujours des projets mais ces projets
sont toujours des clones des uns et des
autres et on parle toujours de la
blockchain avec tout ce qui concerne la
crypto monnaie et toutes les stratégies
qu'on a pu avoir ici et là avec la
fluctuation avec certains plateformes
qui ont été taxées d'une façon
frauduleuse et on oublie que la
technologie blockchain elle offre de
véritables perspectives
donc si tous ensemble on améliore le
cadre juridique la culturation et
l'adhésion nous pouvons nous tous
améliorer la perspective future
moi vous nous tous on a une vie à
changer une vie pour les autres
l'intérêt c'est justement qu'on soit
tous unis afin d'améliorer la
proposition de valeur et permet
justement de dire il y a quelque chose
qu'on peut avoir il y a quelque chose
qu'on peut changer et nous tous on peut
améliorer les choses il y a déjà des
réglementations en cours des
institutions dans le règlement qui
discute avec le gouvernement il y a
aussi des États qui permettent de
transcender l'information parce que la
blockchain elle va devenir
utile pratique et fissurante si tous les
pays du monde par le même langage le
même standard peut-être certains d'entre
vous me diront ok mais la blockchain
dans le train finance on a entendu que
ça n'a pas marché qui avait une
plateforme qui n'a pas échec qui n'a pas
réussi moi j'ai envie de vous dire
c'est plutôt le contraire qu'il faut
voir regardez les téléphones portables
il y a des marques qui ont des pertes il
y a des marques qui sont fleurissantes
toujours dans le même secteur d'activité
là où il faut que regarder c'est le
marché asiatique Singapour Indonésie ou
le train de finance et la blockchain
fait corps et moi j'aurais bien aimé
qu'en Europe on aura la même chose voilà
ce que je voulais devenir ce soir
j'espère avoir votre adhésion et je
souhaite une très bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]